con una amplia mayoría aprobó la cámara
de diputados el proyecto que permite el
tercer retiro de un 10 de los fondos de
pensiones a los chilenos para enfrentar
así la crisis derivada de la pandemia
119 votos a favor 17 en contra y 3
abstenciones una votación contundente
que desata una crisis en el ejecutivo
puesto que el presidente sebastián
piñera y anunció esta semana que va a
llevar la norma al tribunal
constitucional lo que desató una serie
de protestas en las calles durante tres
noches consecutivas barricadas ataques a
comisarías quemas de buses y un
cacerolazo que se escuchó con fuerza no
solo en santiago sino también en el
resto del país mientras son cada vez más
voces no sólo dentro de la oposición
sino también en el oficialismo las que
piden a piñera que reflexione y retire
la solicitud del tribunal constitucional
y promulga esta norma que permitirá a
los chilenos acceder a unos diez mil
millones de dólares según cálculos de
los economistas de sus propios ahorros
para poder pagar cuentas y también
comprar alimentos en estos momentos en
que las ayudas del gobierno no llegan a
toda la población aproximadamente un 20
por ciento de la clase media se queda
afuera aunque el gobierno anunció esta
semana
una ampliación del ingreso familiar de
emergencia a 140 dólares por cabeza una
medida que según dice favorece a 13
millones de chilenos veremos cómo
evoluciona la situación mientras el
martes el tribunal constitucional tiene
en su agenda tratar este tema